[Music]
this
is a murder
hey hey
party people
big ups to hill mount high we started at
the upper middle
and now we're here but for tonight me
casa
i mean you know how the rest of that
goes whoa we gotta live forever
[Applause]
how did this all go so wrong
[Applause]
hop star actor and celebrity
humanitarian xavier was found dead
tonight
his body discovered on the cliff during
an after party for his high school
reunion
this
is a murder whoa
any one of you could be the murderer and
i want to hear your story the same thing
could happen but you see it in a
different way
i want to hear your mind movie
did you see her hair it looks like she
made out with a tornado
it's just jewish hair so much volume
my goal is to find out who killed xavier
now you all went to your high school
reunion
for what second chances at life
love
something else
i would just love it if you could just
skip to the part where the murder
happened i'm telling you a story here
i'm building character arcs dynamics
everybody here hated xavier he's the
worst i'm gonna have sex with your ex
dude
six years old daddy i love him
everyone seems to think you did it
everyone
it's all anyone's talking about
sorry you're you that's not fun
any one of us could snap what who whoa
you want to confess to a murderer
because we need to know who killed him
tonight bam
everybody seems to be hiding something
what is going on
oh
my god
we're done here yeah but you didn't even
know that was fake and you straight up
just chopped off his head
remember that
[Music]
you